Now I do want us to look at the film a little bit more carefully.
Basically a film is the whole process of how
a chemical process is used to convert light.
And the, basically it is the energy of the light itself that changes
the chemicals.
And then of course we have to frill, figure out how to preserve that changed in
chemical process to then basically be able to store light into film.
Here I have just laid out a, a simple 35 millimeter film, pretty much like
the same one that I'm showing here and I basically kind of now unwrapped it.
In the schematic to show different parts of a film.
So in this instance, light is coming in.
And if you notice any one in this one,
the light was coming in from that side, and
that was the one that was pointing to the optics, the the lens of the camera.
The light comes in and, of course, there are many different layers.
Let's just go quickly over them and see what what each one of them does.
First layer is the protective layer.
We need to be able to protect all of these light sensitive layers that
are actually going to exist.
Of course, in most types of cameras and
films like this we also put in a UV filter.
The UV filter is there to just make sure that the right kinds of light, and
not damaging lights, are hitting the different types of sensors.
Ignore the colors of these types of things.
Each one of them has a different feature.
So the first one that the light hits is a blue light layer,
then a yellow filter is added to kind of get the yellow light out,
green light layer, red light layer.
So, again, we have green, red, and blue lights, then there is
an adhesive which is put in there, so these are all very thin layers.
And, of course, thickest one is the film base, which gives it the structure and
keeps it stable.
So in essence, all of this is tied up in something this thin.
So it's important to note that not only in the, in the present days,
people can pack things up in small things,
a lot of this packed up into a very small thing there.
So in essence, a film is a sheet of plastic.
And that's what I've shown you so far.
It's coated with an emulsion that is basically full of light sensitive,
silver halite salts, which have been bonded by a gelatin.
So in essence there are silver halite salts inside the layers.
These are the light sensitive ones that actually store the light changes.
And then there are variable crystals all over the film also, that basically
determine the sensitivity, the contrast, and the resolution of the film.
This is where some issues like ISO come in, because this is where all of
that practicability of how sensitive that film is comes in.